SAM RAMJIL: One of the
most important things
in how we build developer
products is developers.
Communities are
places where people
find meaning, where
they find support,
where they find the real value
in using any kind of tools.
UTTAM KUMAR TRIPATHI: Our
development group community
program is a global
program through which
like-minded communities can
come in and partner with Google.
YUKI ANZAI: We decided
to start our community
to help women who are interested
in technology know each other.
BRITT BARAK: Many people
are doing amazing things.
And also have challenges.
So having together more
people with the same agenda,
it really helps feel
more confident about what
you're doing.
When you figure out that
you're not alone in it,
it gives you some
more drive to do it.
NICK PARFENE: Every single time
I attend an event that we've
put together, I learn.
I thrive from seeing
people come together, solve
their own problems.
SERENA FERNANDES: You see
people that don't even
know each other,
they get together,
and they have, like,
the same passion,
and they start a
friendship or new projects.
YONATAN LEVIN: Also, we tried
to combine different communities
together, like designers
and developers.
Before that, no
one tried to teach
them to speak same language.
DANIEL FRANC: We
partner with hundreds
of communities and organizers
all around the world.
We look for simple ways
to enhance their meetups
or maybe make their
community more successful.
UTTAM KUMAR
TRIPATHI: The program
is currently active worldwide.
We have over 300 communities
who are part of the program.
If you want to come in and
be part of the program,
please show interest, and
we'll get you started.